itself which we've named G it's a composition of operations all of them on N cubits so this is an N
Cubit operation first we have a ZF gate or in other words a phase query gate for the
input function f followed by a layer of hadamard gates and then we have zor which is the phase query gate for the or
function and finally another layer of hatar gates so we see that one iteration in
step two can be implemented by a circuit having the form shown here on the screen and here we have four cubits by the way
but in general we can have any number of cubits a key thing to note here is that we need one query of f to implement G we
need one query to implement ZF and none of the other operations have any dependence on F so they don't require any queries so this number T that
represents the number of times we apply G in step two also represents the number of queries we
need here's a typical way that we might use Grover's algorithm but it's certainly not the only way like I said
before the first thing that we need to do is to choose T and we'll get into that in the next section
for whatever T we choose we run Grover's algorithm for T iterations and we get a candidate solution
X there's no guarantee that X is really a solution but we can spend one additional query to check if we have a solution then we can
output that solution and stop and otherwise we can either try again possibly with a different choice of T
but not necessarily or we can give up and report that there aren't any solutions like a I said before this is
not the only way the algorithm might be used but this is a natural way of applying it to the search problem next we'll see what the grover
operation actually does to the state of the N cubits that it acts on let's think of our n cubits as
forming a single register which I'll name Q just to pick a name remember that what we do first in
Grover's algorithm is to put Q into a uniform superposition of all nbit strings and we do that by applying hatar
Gates to n cubits in the all zero State we then iterate the grover operation G and then
measure it's going to be helpful to partition the set of all nbit strings into two sets a z and
A1 a Zer contains all of the strings that cause F to evaluate to zero and A1 contains all of the strings that cause F
to evaluate to one another way to say that is that A1 contains all the solutions to our search
problem while a z contains all of the non-solutions we'll be especially
interested in two Quantum States one is the uniform superposition over all of the non-solutions that's k a z and the
other is uniform over all the solutions and that one is Kat A1 I should point out that these definitions only make
sense when these sets are non-empty because otherwise we're summing up zero things and dividing by zero and as we go
through this analysis of Grover's algorithm we will be making that assumption we can very easily figure out what
Grover's algorithm does when f is either the constant zero function or the constant one function by treating them as special cases but I will leave that
for you to do on your own not surprisingly if every string is a solution we will indeed obtain a
solution when we measure and if there aren't any solutions then we won't obtain one because in that case there aren't
any but for the sake of this analysis we're going to assume that both of these sets are nonm empty so that these
definitions of these two states make sense by the way this is a pretty common
notation whenever we have a non-empty finite set s we can write c s to mean the uniform superposition over the
elements of that set just like we have here so let's collect these definitions like this and we'll see how they connect
to Grover's algorithm the first step of Grower's algorithm is the initialization step which puts Q into a uni form
superposition over all nbit strings and just to give this state an easily recognizable name I'm going to call it
cat u u is short for uniform it's important for the sake of the analysis that we first note that
this uniform State Catu is contained in the Subspace spanned by the two vectors K a0 and K
A1 in particular if we take the linear combination of these two states that's shown here on the screen we'll get cat
U now the key to the entire analysis is the fact that the state of Q remains in
this two-dimensional Subspace no matter how many times we apply the grover operation so everything is going to boil
down to what happens in a two-dimensional Subspace now let's see what the grover operation does and in particular what it
does to vectors in the two-dimensional Subspace spanned by cat a0 and K
A1 it's helpful to imagine that g is split into two parts one part is the ZF
gate and the other part is the zor gate sandwiched between two layers of hadamard
gates here's the definition of ZF from before and it's pretty straightforward from that definition to see that its
action on our two states the uniform superpositions of non-solutions and solutions is simply to put a minus sign
in front of K A1 well nothing happens to K a0 and that's all we really need to know
about ZF for the sake of this analysis for the second part which is
the Z orgate sandwi between two layers of hatar gates let's start by recalling how zor is defined one way to write it
is as is shown on the screen this is the same expression as before and another way to express it using the direct
notation is like this and you can verify this expression just by thinking about how the operation on
the right hand side acts on standard basis States in particular it does nothing to the all zero State and every
other standard basis state gets a minus sign which agrees with the definition of Z
or so if we sandwich this operation between two layers of hadamard gates then we get a similar expression except
that in place of the all zero standard basis State we now have our uniform sub position k u and that's because H tensor
n transforms the L zero standard basis state to k u and also H tensor n is its own conjugate transpose so it works in a
similar way acting from the right on the bra rather than the cat and now we're going to figure out
what G does to our two vectors a0 and A1 using the facts that we've just
observed let's start with a0 first let's sub itute the expression
we obtained for the Z orgate sandwiched between two layers of hadamar Gates next we can use the fact that ZF does nothing